bonjour c'est gianni au poney bien dans
la peau d'une élite c'est formidable de
toute façon je suis en attente de dieu
john et les sosies de johnny hallyday
ils sont nombreux et traverse les âges
et la télévision ne manque pas de faire
leur portrait voici en 1991 janeiro à 36
ans et ancien charpentier de marine
commence à percer dans le monde du
spectacle sous le nom de johnny rock
sosie de l'autre johnny sur scène je vis
les mêmes émotions puis quand les gens
s'éclatent avec moi quand le public
s'éclate bon ben je ressens ce qui est
luis rocha
lui aussi donné tout sur scène en 1994
johnny de besançon ne passait pas
inaperçu ont renoncé je cause henri
jacques o henry remplissait les salles
mais avait un peu de mal à gérer son
succès au moment où je dois être libre
j'ai toujours à peu près une trentaine
de personnes qui hélas autour de moi
tremblement de des autographes des
souvenirs
pas facile la vie de sosie d'autant que
pour ressembler à son idole il faut
donner de sa personne en 2009 pour
johnny love l'état maquillage était
crucial
le plus le plus dur c'est d'arriver à
faire les yeux de johnny parce que
bon je pars quand même tout à fait le
même regard faut pas rêver non plus et
une fois la préparation terminé la
ressemblance est telle que certains s'y
perd un peu vous vous sentez vous même
là où vous vous sentez un autre je suis
johnny johnny wide web
mais en même temps vous êtes johnny
voyez johnny oil moi même heureusement
johnny vegas pouvait compter sur sa
fiancée pour lui ramener les pieds sur
terre je suis là un petit peu pour le
rappeler à l'ordre de temps à autre et
lui rappeler que dans sa vie privée il
doit rester vincent car la passion peut
parfois être débordante être sosie de
johnny c'est avant tout être fan comme
johnny cabaret en 2011 il ouvrait les
portes de son angle bienvenue dans
l'univers de géniale idée que je
collectionne depuis
1979 qu'est ce qui vous plaît autant
chez johnny pour avoir des milliers
d'objets tous et malice et c'est plus
grand amour qu'on peut rencontrer je
pense un amour partagé par sept autres
fans et sosie du taulier jean baptiste
guégan
chose
sa ressemblance avec johnny n'est pas
physique mais vocale mais c'est l'un des
sosies les plus célèbres en 2019 son
album s'était vendu à plus de 200000
exemplaires c'est pas moi que je suis
génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]